ich habe sie gefragt und Frage noch
einmal und dann höre gerne Antwort
bekommen sie dramatisieren die Situation
sie dramatisieren die Situation wie ich
finde zurecht
und sagen wir die letzte Generation
wissen wie es besser geht das habe ich
nie gesagt aber die letzte Generation
sagt das sie haben
Lösungsmöglichkeiten die sie auch hier
in dieser Sendung ich habe oft geschaut
und lernen
die meisten Vertreter sagen dann wir
wollen ich muss es wiederholen 9 €
Ticket und Tempo 100 jetzt haben sie
noch irgendeine Geschichte dazu gegeben
glauben Sie ernsthaft dass wenn sie so
engagieren und dadurch die reizschwellen
immer höher treiben auch reitschwellen
der Gewalt der Aggression glauben Sie
dass die Verhältnismäßigkeit ihrer
Lösung zu diesen Aktionen und zu dem
Ziel das Klima besser zu machen
glaubwürdiges wer hat mich ja gebeten
außer dass sie so allgemein immer
erzählen das können wir alle
unterschreiben alles was Sie sagen
das ist ein dramatisches Thema und wenn
wir dieses Thema nicht ernst nehmen ob
letzte vorletzte fünf letzte Generation
ist sterben auch heute und seit zehn
Generationen Menschen an diesem
Klimawandel und Afrika hat uns trotzdem
nicht interessiert ich bin bei ihm wo
ich nicht so klar weiß ob ich bei Ihnen
sein kann ist auch wenn sie so
respektierlich von Fridays for future
reden und sagen sie sind eigentlich die
die heute das wirkliche Thema besetzen
ich glaube dass weniger ich glaube dass
diese Art die gerade Fridays for future
und als sie noch junge Menschen waren
und Erwachsene wie Sie und ich sie uns
nicht gekauft haben uns beeindruckt
haben über ihre Regelmäßigkeit über ihre
ganz gerade demonstrationsform keine
Gewalt gar nichts dass die den Humus
gesetzt haben dass sie sich draufsetzen
können und ihren Gewaltaktionen das
Thema positionieren zu dem wie statt zu
der Frage und was geht es wirklich aber
meine Frage Ihre Institution sagt mit
neun Euro Tempo 100 und gesellschaftsrat
verändert sich die Lage dazu würde ich
gerne Ihre Meinung hören
okay Klasse 9 Euro Ticket und 100 und
Ende wird von 100 auf deutschen Autobahn
das waren Forderungen wo ganz klar aber
das erste Sicherheitsmaßnahmen das war
auch noch vor dem letzten Winter wo wir
ganz klar ganz klar gesagt wurde okay
das sind Maßnahmen wo wir nicht nur
massiv CO2 sparen Energie sparen sondern
eben auch Menschen ähm das Geld in der
Tasche lassen das waren einfachste
sicherheitsmaßen die die wir gefordert
haben
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen ja klar wir müssen
also wir müssen ja runter vom CO2 und
das wäre dann eben erste Ansätze gewesen
und gesagt haben okay ähm so und dann
die Bundesregierung hat die nicht
umgesetzt
sage und dann haben wir gesagt okay was
ich daraus ergibt nicht mal diese
einfachsten Sachen für Tempo mit 100 das
kostet uns nicht mal was wirklich
nicht mal das schafft sie und dann ist
daraus die Konsequenz gewesen die
Bundesregierung schafft es nicht sie ist
orientierungslos wie das eigene
Beratungsgremium gesagt hat also muss
sie sich helfen lassen man muss sie sich
helfen lassen von der Gesellschaft und
das ist eben von der Gesellschaft von
uns als Gesellschaft und das ist eben
der gesellschaftsrat und das ist eben
auch diese faszinierende Ideen der wir
sind ja also es geht um 160 Menschen es
gibt von Menschen die zusammen kommen
die werden zusammengelost und zwar auf
die Art und Weise dass Sie unsere
Gesellschaft möglichst gut abbilden
los richtig Menschen zu zufällig und und
das ist auch ein und das ist auch ein
Vorteil okay das ist es ist insofern
Vorteil aber wenn sie jetzt zufällig 90
Klima Leuten auch egal okay also die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist natürlich sehr
sehr gering über Losverfahren kriegen
wir kriegen wir mit einer
Wahrscheinlichkeit eben eine Abdeckung
von der Gesellschaft wie sie ist
160 Leuten können wir jetzt über die
Zahl sicher unterhalten der die
Grundidee ist einfach Demokratie zu tun
was hat das noch mit dem Recht für das
Volk zu sprechen zu tun
also die Idee ist 160 leute das ist das
was die gesellschaftsrat nennen die
bestimmen Sie per Los also nicht ich
nein nein
das stimmt immer gerne mit dass das wir
als letzte Generation bestimmen dass
dann irgendwelche Leute
gehen ich habe sie immer gern ganz
konkret sie ganz gerne ganz konkret
haben dafür bewerben und habe ich dann
vielleicht keine Zeit genommen
ist sie trifft dann melden Sie sich
zurück sondern unter 84 Millionen
Menschen oder nicht
diese Konzepte
bitte
84 Millionen Menschen
und von den nehmen Sie 160 Personen raus
ob das jetzt 16
alles technische Dinge die wir über die
sich wahrscheinlich auf einer anderen
Sendung sprechen können weil wenn ich
jetzt anfange das technisch zu erklären
dann wird wieder reingegangen und gesagt
das demokratisch ich würde sagen keine
quantitative Frage des Demokratie
immer egal welche Demokratie gesagt
haben das Volk wählt die freie
Willensentscheidung wer aus welchen
Parteien dann die Repräsentation macht
und das Lernen Kompromisse zu schließen
das ist unser demokratischer Ansatz das
ist ihre Legitimation seit wann ein Los
einen Menschen in der Demokratie
legitimieren darf Entscheidungen für
alle mitzumachen gesagt es kommt darauf
an bei diesen partizipativen ansetzen
das gibt's ja durch das ist aber eine
andere Geschichte als die wir sie jetzt
erzählen beratendes Gremium sein sollte
Ende erzählen oder ob es ein
Entscheidungsgremium sein soll das wäre
in unserer Demokratie nicht möglich
deswegen müssen wir das eben zu Ende
hören wie das wirklich aussehen soll mal
gerne verstehen also 160 Menschen die
losen sie aus sie sagen die sind
rettensentativ für 84 Millionen ich weiß
es bringt eine eine möglichst gute
Abbildung ich bin ja nicht nur Mann ich
bin auch ich bin noch Akademiker die
Wissenschaft die sie so gerne zitieren
sagen was für ein Quatsch also 160
Menschen sind bei Meinungsumfragen ist
das Minimum 1000 besser noch 2000 und
noch besser noch mehr das zu haben was
man an der repräsentative
Meinungsumfrage nennt es geht ja aber
nicht um Meinungsumfragen sondern es
geht darum wirklich Lösungen zu
erarbeiten
lassen
das dauert nur so lange ist es ist ein
Spielchen es ist für meine Begriffe nur
ein Spielchen man kann sowas ja mal
machen das können Sie auch jetzt machen
z.B können Sie 160 Leute zusammenrufen
ja machen und dann können Sie mal sehen
ob die Politiker darauf reagieren oder
ob sie nicht reagieren habe ich ja gar
nichts gegen kann man ja machen aber
dass das die Lösung des Problems ist
dass da irgendwelche Psychiater
kioskverkäufer und ich weiß nicht was
jetzt über das klimaberatschlagen dass
das glaube ich ist illusionär und das
Problem was ich sehe ist mehr die Art
und Weise wie sie das hier darstellen
die Art und Weise wie sie das absolut
darstellen als absolute moralische
Position als Lösung der ganzen Probleme
und das finde ich wirklich problematisch
und ich kann das nur wiederholen ich
glaube dass sie dem Anliegen ähm
gegen was gegen
die Schaden ja ich glaube dass das also
frei ist von future hat glaube ich viel
bewusst dann geschaffen das haben die
auch gut gemacht
ganz kritisch ganz kritisch reagiert auf
sie haben das nachher relativiert das
weiß ich aber ich glaube dass die Mensch
der Menschen die wir gerade eben gesehen
haben das bin ich natürlich auch nicht
diese Form der Gewalt ja aber das ist
eine Form von symmetrischer Eskalation
wie man das nennt und es ist und sie
sagen immer sie sind gewaltfrei ja sie
sind ohne militante Gewalt das stimmt
auch und ich glaube dass sie Moment ich
habe ja noch nicht es ist keine
militante Gewalt aber es ist für meine
Begriffe eine Form dass sie mich mit
Gewalt davon abhalten z.B meine
sterbende Mutter zu besuchen oder so
etwas gar nicht so dramatisieren als
Jurist wenn ich das noch mal deutlich
machen
retardierende Gewalt das alles kann man
vergessen Freiheitsberaubung ist
Strafgesetz
Nötigung ist Strafgesetz das ist die
Bewegungsfreiheit von Menschen
einzuschränken eine der ganz großen
Freiheitsgrundrechte und die anderen
Dinge will ich schon gar nicht zitieren
wir müssen uns wenigstens an dem Punkt
einig sein wenn sie behaupten dass sie
gewaltfrei sind dann leben sie in einer
anderen Welt in dem Moment wo sie sich
ankleben und andere Menschen in ihrer
Bewegungsfreiheit einschränken haben sie
jedenfall Straftatbestände erfüllt ich
will jetzt gar nicht sagen ob das vor
Gericht kommt und was für Urteile kommen
aber wenn die an dem Punkten auch noch
schwätzen von zivilen Ungehorsam ein
Rechtsinstitut dass es nicht gibt es
gibt im Grundgesetz
Widerstandsrecht der Bevölkerung wenn
die Bevölkerung sieht dass die
Institution des Staates die Demokratie
zerstören wenn sie aber jetzt gesagt
haben dass es keine Gewalt dann habe ich
Probleme weil andere würden dann ihnen
folgen für ganz andere Ziele auch
wiederum Gewalt ausüben und ich finde
diese Eskalation von Gewalt und gegen
Gewalt führt in der Regel meist zu mehr
Gewalt als Stadt zu weniger und ich
glaube dass wir
Aufmerksamkeit und darum geht's doch ich
meine naja auf einer Studentin in den
68er und ich kenne das alles sie
brauchen und das sage ich sehr sehr mit
großem Respekt sie brauchen
Aufmerksamkeit für das Ziel dass sie
vertreten aber wenn ihr nichts anderes
mehr einfällt als Gewaltaktion dann ist
er ein Problem ihre Kreativität dass dem
Ziel nicht nutzt sie haben wie viel Tage
im Polizeiwagen verbracht insgesamt
man das wahrscheinlich sieben oder acht
Tage ja in Isolation
Sie Verständnis dafür also es sagt ihnen
ja das ist da ein Problem mit dem Gesetz
gibt
ich möchte aber wirklich sagen dass es
friedliche Proteste sind und dass sie
auch einen großen Teil so wahrgenommen
werden also wenn ich zum Beispiel mit
der Polizei in Kontakt bin dann wird das
als friedlich wahrgenommen und auch mit
anderen Menschen auch auf der Straße
gesehen also ich provoziere ja nicht
aktiv Gewalt es kommen sicherlich zu zu
Gewalt Ausbrüchen also das haben wir ja
gesehen das haben wir gerade gesehen
sicherlich auch sicherlich Sie dafür
Verständnis also wenn ich in diesem
Protesten wenn dann bin ich demütig
gegen wenn der Mensch auch aggressiv auf
mich zukommen ich kann natürlich
verstehen dass der Mensch ist absolut
macht das ja auch nicht ich mache das
nicht gerne ich glaube das ist eben sehr
wirksam ist da dass wir uns hinsetzen
und wenn wir das dann auch langsam
wollen über Lösungsansätze dieser
gesellschaftsrat
oder der Gedanke das heißt sie wählen
diese 160 Leute die losen sie per Zufall
und die machen was die beraten die
Bundesregierung oder wie also das ganze
funktioniert so das basiert auf einem
auf einem Prinzip das auch schon häufig
durchgeführt wurde auf diesen Bürger
retten wozu es auch zum Thema Klima
schon sogar schon mal einen gab wo Horst
Köhler der Schirmherr war ja und die
Menschen kommen zusammen und werden dann
eben auf einen gleichen Wissensstand
gesetzt durch Expertinnen und Experten
müssen aber nicht die Expertinnen und
Experten die das entscheiden sondern das
sind eben die Menschen die diese die
Leute hören
und dann
zusammen im kleinen Gruppen gehen wo
wohne Moderation auch stattfindet das
heißt dass jede Meinung gehört wird dass
jeder Mensch aus seinem Alltag auch
schildern kann und dann hat dieser
gesellschaftsrat eine ganz klare Aufgabe
und die Aufgabe ist wie schaffen wir das
sozialgerecht so dass wir das alle
tragen können in dieser Gesellschaft wie
schaffen wir das bis 2030 rauszukommen
aus was wir in der Gegenüber das
schaffen müssen das ist eine
physikalische gegeben
160 Leute den trauen sie sozusagen mehr
zu als 730 Abgeordneten des Deutschen
Bunde
lassen Sie mich danach auch gerne darauf
eingehen warum sie haben schon gesagt
von der repräsentativen Demokratie das
heißt also unsere Gesellschaft wird
irgendwie abgebildet
diese Abbildung ist aber nicht also ja
wir haben dann eine Person gewählt die
irgendwie für uns abstimmen soll aber
diese Abbildung ist einfach nicht
existierend im Bundestag sind 86 Prozent
Akademikerinnen in der Regel in der
Bevölkerung sind 14 % und dieser
Unterschied dieser dieser
sagt mir dass diese Abbildung nicht
stattfindet
sich bitte einfach genauso ist es eben
bei alten und neuen Bundesländern im
Alter und so weiter und das ist eben
etwas was dieser gesellschaftsrat
schaffen kann dass er wirklich eine
Abbildung unserer Gesellschaft bilden
kann
ganz kurz
oder 30 Leute sitzen bundestagsabkommen
sie sagen da sitzen 85% Akademiker dann
sage ich Ihnen das ist tatsächlich
bedauerlich da sollten mehr Handwerker
sitzen da sollten auch viel mehr Frauen
sitzen und so weiter gar keine Frage nur
wenn die Leute vor Ort diesen akadem der
möglicherweise an Jurist ist wie Herr
Friedmann oder vielleicht dann ein
kluger Theologe wie Herr Lutz oder
superschlaue Frau wie Frau büks wenn die
dir reinwählen und sagen was auf schick
mal lieber Frau Büchs dahin weil die
kann im Zweifel ein Gesetzestext
verstehen und die versteht dann aber
auch weil sie aus dem aus dem Leben
kommt die nicht akademisch abgehoben
völlig irgendwo im Elfenbeinturm die
kommt aus dem Leben und der traurig zu
dass sie mir meine Interessen irgendwie
durchsetzen das ist Demokratie aber das
ist
komplett falsch verstanden
zu ihrer Konklusion die einfach nicht
stimmt egal jetzt wer wo sitzt Robert
habecks Problem war dass er eben nicht
die soziale Problematik in seinem Gesetz
berücksichtigt hat und jetzt lassen wir
über alle Partei Spielen raus diese
Fehler wurde ihm dann klar gemacht und
dieser Bundestag auch da
parteienübergreifend weil auch die
Koalitionsparteien haben das genau
gespürt ein Gesetz dass das nicht
mitträgt hat in diesem Land keine breite
Mahlzeit und die Frage die wir uns immer
Stellen ist die Verhältnismäßigkeit auch
das Spannungsgefälle zwischen Ökonomie
Ökologie und der sozialen Frage und ich
musste ehrlich sagen ihre These die sie
eben hatten der Bundestag seit so wie er
besetzt nicht in der Lage das zu bringen
und der gesellschaftsrat mehr das war
sehr beeindruckend neben vielen anderen
Punkten der Kritik es ist daran gelegen
neben dem dass die Leute nicht
mitgenommen wurden dass das mit heißer
Nagel gestrickt wurde das ein ganzes
Thema vergessen
bevor wir diese Idee des
gesellschaftsrates ganzer reden möchte
ich da noch was positives dazu sagen es
gibt viele Beispiele dass das durchaus
Foren sein können die helfen können in
den eine Großbritannien hat es gegeben
bei der Krankenversicherung da hat
solche gesellschaftsräte gegeben die
waren das war durchaus erfolgreich das
können wichtige Impulse sein die können
vieles aufgreifen die können tatsächlich
da bin ich bei Herrn Schnarr zu einer
Verständigung beitragen ich würde das
nicht zerreden wollen ich glaube nur als
das übergreifende Ziel das passt
sozusagen das passen soll zur Form der
Proteste
dass das geht irgendwie nicht richtig
zusammen und deswegen würde ich würde
ich uns alle ermuntern wollen diese Art
von partizipativen
Elementen für die Demokratie zu nutzen
und all das zu nutzen was sie uns
bringen können und ihn würde ich
empfehlen
ein anderes Hauptziel anzusehen denn
sonst werden die Leute sauer weil die
wieder das ist das gleiche Problem sagen
ich stehe im Stau für irgendwas wo ich
denke das kann es nicht reichen
und genau das ist der erste Punkt wo ich
wieder ein großes Fragezeichen der
Glaubwürdigkeit habe wenn jemand oder
eine Gruppe so ein absolutheitszeichen
setzt es geht um Klima bei aller Liebe
auch für Themen gesellschaftspolitische
ob man gesellschaftsräte expertenräte
macht aber mir soll bitte einer erklären
ob die Frage des gesellschaftsrates in
den nächsten drei bis fünf Jahren so
lange wird das wahrscheinlich dauern bis
sie dann auch wirken ihr Ziel keine
Stunde ist zu verlieren beim Klima mich
mitnimmt wenn ich im Stau stehe
es gibt oder gibt's da noch andere wir
haben also eine Lösung finden fürs Klima
zuständig gibt's da noch einen kitarat
und ein ich sag ja bereits
es soll eine klare Ausrichtung geben und
die klare Ausrichtung sein wie schaffen
wir das bis 2030 aus der Nutzung für
viele
Energieträger und vor allem wie schaffen
wir das sozial gerecht weil wir haben
das ja jetzt gesehen sie haben das ja
auch gesagt Herr Friedmann wir müssen
das auf eine Art und Weise schaffen dass
es von der Gesellschaft getragen wird
und jetzt haben wir die Situation da
kommt eine Idee und jede Partei fängt
irgendwie an darauf zu prügeln und dann
haben wir eine Spaltung und Lager wir
haben auch in der Bevölkerung eine
Spaltung in Lager und die einen finden
es vielleicht gut die anderen schlecht
und die kommen sicherlich auch durch
sozialen Medien die sie vorhin gesagt
haben die kommen nicht dazu wirklich
effektiv miteinander zu diskutieren und
die Frage ist ihm wie kommen wir da raus
weil wenn wir wenn wir das nicht
schaffen dann akzeptieren wir
dann akzeptieren wir all die
katastrophalen Auswirkungen die wir
jetzt schon geschildert haben
was dieser gesellschaftsrat schafft ist
das aus den verschiedenen Lagern
einzelne Menschen ähm geholt werden die
dann eben auf Augenhöhe miteinander
diskutieren können in moderierten
Gesprächen wo sie ihre eigene Meinung
ihre eigenen alltäglichen Situation
rausbringen können um dann einen einen
Maßnahmenkatalog einen lösungskatalog zu
erarbeiten
ja dann so wie er ist an die
Bundesregierung gegeben
als Gesellschaft tragen die Ausrichtung
ist klar dass es soll ein ein
Lösungspaket gefunden werden wie wir
diese kritische Frage wie verbesserte
diese wirklich kritische Frage
[Musik]
die bekommen wie gesagt bekommen die
einen auf die Kombi auf den gleichen
Wissensstand
das Thema das Thema und dementsprechend
ein wahnsinniges Misstrauen gegenüber
dieser Demokratie ein wahnsinniges
Misstrauen und umgekehrt eine
wissenschaftlich ganz kurz eine
Wissenschaft glaube ich kann wahnsinnig
schwer tue sie sagten vorhin drei Jahre
wir haben noch drei Jahre Zeit das haben
sie gesagt
oder nicht mehr verstehen
kürzlich jemanden hier der sagte wir
haben noch sechs Jahre und ein paar
Monate Zeit und schon da hat mich dieses
absolute ja einfach Zeit das ist so ein
Satz der steht dann da so und dann wird
man das so hin und dann fahren
ich habe noch ein anderes Thema ähm
stimmt es dass sie deswegen diese
Aktionen auch gegen Privatjets und
irgendwelche teuren Geschäfte auf Sylt
und Golfplatz und so weitermachen weil
sie sagen
diese sogenannten reichen dieses eine
Prozent verursacht 15 Prozent der
Emissionen weltweit
ist das das ist sicherlich Teil davon
das ist eine also die Situation
verursacht 15% der Emissionen
sind das ist glaube ich gut belegt wie
kommt man auf solche Zahlen Deutschland
verursacht keine zwei es geht ja also
das ist das je nachdem welche Statistik
sie sich angucken mich dann diese
Statistik die sieht naja schauen Sie
diese Statistik die Sie diese zitiert
haben mit dem einen Prozent des
reichsten Prozent das ist weltweit
soweit ich diese Studie noch im
Hinterkopf war mit solchen Zahlen
ständig ja aber es ist doch es ist doch
aber eine zum Himmel schreiende
Ungerechtigkeit aber das 1 % der
kontrolliert das wäre mist das wer weiß
das so genau das sind die
Wissenschaftler und Wissenschaft je
nachdem welche Statistik man nimmt also
schon welcher vertrauen Sie welcher vor
allem Vertrauen vor allem den Verhalten
Nationen also dem ähm mit dem ipcci es
gibt eine Reise
es gibt schon eine Reihe von Studien die
zeigen dass mit dem Einkommen ganz klar
der co2-abdruck steigt und das auch die
in Anführungszeichen obersten Prozent
ein überproportional großen ein Prozent
verursacht 15 % der gesamten Emissionen
das ist die Verbindung die dar verteilt
wird und ich bin deswegen darüber
gestolpert ich sage Ihnen auch warum
eigentlich ist das alles Schall und
Rauch aber ich finde deswegen drüber
gestolpert weil ich gelesen habe den den
Artikel einer einer Psychologin die sich
bei ihnen mit angemeldet hat und die
genau das beschrieben hat und sagt das
ist Teil dieses ganzen Systems das ganze
möglichst horrormäßig Apokalypsen artig
zu beschreiben und das ist etwas womit
ich wirklich ein Problem habe sie haben
auch folgendes interessant schon ein
bisschen her und sie sagt Milliarden
Menschen werden sich auf den Weg machen
Milliarden Menschen werden sterben ich
erinnere mich an Zeiten haben wir hier
in der Sendung gesessen aber von
Millionen Menschen die Rede die
irgendwann durch
Klimaveränderung auf der Flucht sein
werden sie tun es nicht mehr unter
Milliarden ich habe damit ein Problem
sagen die die genau das beschreibt das
ist ein wirtschaftlich und das ist eine
Publikation was darum geht in welchen in
welchen Bereichen die Menschheit sich
aufgehalten hat in ihrer langen
Geschichte und der einfach sagen und
diese Bereiche werden kann nicht mehr
existieren bis zur Mitte des
Jahrhunderts wird einfach wird und und
das ist das was was diese Studie gibt
die schauen sich nur die Temperatur an
und sagen ein Drittel der Menschheit
also die die Bereiche wo jetzt eben bis
ein Drittel der Menschheit wohnen die
werden dann nicht mehr bewohnbar sein
also müssen die Menschen woanders
hingehen und deswegen und deswegen habe
ich das gesagt
wir können uns doch also wir können
jetzt wieder anfangen uns irgendwelche
Statistiken und und Studien und Herzen
werfen worauf wir uns vielleicht einigen
können ist dass wir die Vereinten
Nationen als belastbare Quelle nehmen
kann und die Vereinten Nationen
beschreiben das was wir da gerade sehen
beschreiben diese diese Erhitzung diese
Krise in der wir sind und dass wir da
nicht rauskommen dieser torische
Bedrohung und wenn die Vereinten Nation
das sagen
aber es geht ab und dann sagen Sie mir
ja aber sie haben eigentlich ja nicht
absolute
wahr
zurückholen auf unsere Thema dass wir zu
dis Gehirn haben nämlich was passiert in
dieser Gesellschaft wo sind die
Friktionen wo sie die Monolog und
Dialoge und bei allem Respekt vor der
letzten Generation ist das ja nur ein
kleiner Bestandteil aber er hat zum
Beispiel etwas ähnliches mit anderen die
sich dauernd jetzt
Protestaktionen oder Parteien oder
wählen nämlich die
da ist immer auch ein Stück
Selbstüberschätzung immer auch ein Stück
absolutieren der eigenen Meinung nicht
immer anders hier mit Grundlagen die
zweifelhaft sind und es ist immer ein
wir gegen die anderen und das
polarisiert die Gesellschaft je länger
solche Aktionen laufen oder wir erklären
euch die Welt ein gutes Deutschland ist
nur ein Deutschland das National ist und
die Grenzen ist und wer das nicht
versteht ist Apriori nicht mehr
zuverlässig zur Diskussion